[Musique]
voici la toute première image en
couleurs envoyé depuis une autre planète
une première historique
ces trois premiers clichés ont été
transmis par la sonde martienne
persévérance après son atterrissage hier
des clichés d'une qualité exceptionnelle
sur l'un d'eux pris depuis le propulseur
le robot apparaît très nettement
elon musk promettent un premier vol
habité vers mars des 2026 est carrément
un million de colons sur la planète
rouge d'ici 2050
son rival jeff bezos s'est dotée de la
même puissance financière
le patron d'amazon pense qu'à terme 90 %
de l'humanité vivra dans l'espace dans
des cités cylindres géante la rotation
reproduire à la gravité et permettra à
l'agriculture
[Musique]
pas de l'été
si nos industries et notre population
continue à croître
l'espace sera le seul endroit où aller
la terre finira par être une magnifique
zone de résidence et d'industrie légère
on viendra en visite ou y faire des
études mais tout le reste et notamment
les industries polluantes sera fait en
dehors de notre planète
impitoyable météo ici dans la banlieue
de dallas personne ne s'attendait à ça
maintenant on est en matière les files
d'attentes s'allongent devant les
supermarchés
certains rayons sont vides pire plus de
la moitié des habitants sont privés
d'eau potable
le thermomètre a plongé jusqu'à -18
dans certaines maisons le gel a fait
exploser les canalisations pour colmater
les fuites c'est le système d et pour le
quotidien il faut s'adapter
on ne peut plus prendre de douche pour
tirer la chasse d'eau
on prend de l'eau dans le jacuzzi et
puis cette annonce de la demande de
divorce de kim kardashian la star
américaine de télé-réalité mettant un
terme à son mariage avec le rappeur et
entrepreneurs kanye west
un couple très populaire mariés depuis
2006 14 l'a clairement j'ai les boules
j'ai quand j'ai besoin de me répondre je
suis éclatée et je suis dégoûté a perdu
la première manche mais après bon
deuxième 300 km au filet ça il avait les
yeux et ça sort du plus d'une poule à il
faut le laver
non je crois qu'elle le chili mais oui
je suis juré de la merde à chaque fois
chiant maintenant c'est sûr alors le 5
qu'est ce que c'est que ce truc
kaka coca dans l'une de kaka graff l'île
de coco l'huile de coco le moment le
plus douloureux de votre vie quand je
vais aux toilettes les plus joyeux quand
j'en sors ali michèle on commence au et
on va chercher ce qui se passe entre 5
et 9 hertz envoya les viols fait mal
mais michel a constaté à l'échographie
que j'avais tout qui tremblaient
[Musique]
quand soudain rien c'est apparemment une
curieuse nouvelles preuves de virilité
sur les réseaux sociaux
l'épilation du visage et du torse à la
cire d'un seul courrier les vidéos de ce
barbier néerlandais ont atteint des
chiffres stratosphériques certaines
dépassent les 20 millions de vues de
premier abord elle pourrait faire
sourire surtout quand c'est une excuse
pour s'exhiber torse nu mais la pratique
est dangereuse
l'association des dermatologues
britanniques s'alarme sur twitter pour
des risques de suffocation et
d'allergies sévères à la fin du dernier
concert de ntm
vous dites avoir violé comme une petite
chatte on peut on peut l'entendre dans
quoi ça or la semaine dernière c'était
l'affairé richard berry cette semaine
c'est ppda on a réagi très différemment
à ces deux affaires berry on sait tous
si aucun richard berry alors que ppda
s'est tous dit aucun seulement
maintenant le journal le monde se
demande pourquoi tant d'amour pour
samuel etienne pour le huffington post
vous êtes l'animateur le plus cool de la
télé le héros de la presse sur twitch
pour la nouvelle république
certains vous imagine même en président
oui c'est vrai oui mais des admirateurs
j'imagine et ont dessiné votre affiche
de campagne la france
etienne avec jeux de mots jeux l'épauler
on parle et répète montant forfaitaire
est complètement incompétent badioli
ajouté le religieux
roger des règles pour que free veut
bon je sais rien à faire ici dans ce
cauchemar
de toute évidence car je ferai tout pour
que ça s'arrête pas et ça s'arrêtera pas
en quoi la france tap et paradoxale y
avait les colonies d'ailleurs je
rappelle que le ministre des colonies
l'époque s'appelait blaise diagne et la
même année son fils raoul diagne vote en
équipe de france si on l'applaudît ce
pays bizarre il colonise elle est en
même temps un noir pouvait voir une
bière sur une terrasse française ouais
j'aime ce pays pour ça commence à peine
henri salvador salvador quand il était
jeune il s'est choisi de kylie adam bâ
pc des six est plus actuelle riesser
j'ai eu une chance folle j'ai fait une
belle gang non c'est plutôt la gérance
qui lui quand vous dites à un monde qui
avait un aviateur vietnam et en 14 18
dans l'armée française il vous crois pas
mais il peut pas vous croire vous voulez
le plus gros vendeur de disques et de
scopitone dans les années 60 c'est
slimane azem hausser mon pays si je
raconte pas l'histoire de mon pays mais
c'est aussi picasso jamais étaient
français ce que ça aussi qui est
intéressant à raconter à ses gamins du
coin qui vient de se plaindre aussi et
pleurer blindés au coco avant toi
paulette nardal elle est la première
femme noire à la sorbonne
l école a ouvert une porte ça voulait
dire quelque chose voilà ce qui se passe
quand c'est une femme qui manie le
tractopelle dans une casse
tout doit être nickel dont des
poussières dont ce coup orange on balaye
époque c'est réglé après on attaque leur
passage donc bloqué vous mecs quoi alors
il écrit l'histoire par exemple je sais
pas moi si vous voulez bob dylan je
fasse ça vous dit quelque chose ou david
bowie ça vous dit quelque chose non plus
bon alors écoutez qu'est ce que je vais
je dors yale vous tombe je pense que qui
avait loupé oui je vous laisse méditer
cette maxime du grand philosophe pierre
dac
ceux qui ne savent rien en savent
toujours autant que ceux qui n'en savent
pas plus qu'eux